problem 33 asks what distance did Jane
travel Jane travel what distance does
she travel so one bill traveled 40 miles
in 40 minutes bill 40 miles in 40
minutes are essentially a mile a minute
which 60 miles an hour whatever a 1 mile
a minute right that's what we could
figure out one mile per minute per
minute that has no information about how
far did Jane travel it's useless
to Jane traveled at the same average
rate as Bill so that tells us that Jane
also if she'd go into the average rate
of bill that means that she also went
one mile per minute but we're not asking
for how fast did Jane travel or what was
her average rate we're asking for how
far did she travel so with statements 1
& 2 combined all we know is Jane's rate
but we don't know how long she traveled
for so we don't know the distance so the
answer is e that both statements
together are not sufficient if if
statement 2 told us that Jane traveled
at the same rate as Bill and she
traveled at that rate for 10 minutes
then we would we would be able to solve
this problem but it didn't so even with
both pieces information we still don't
know how far
Jane traveled me now how fast she
traveled 34 what number is 15 percent of
X so what we want to know is 0.15 X
that's what we're trying to solve for
statement 1 tells us 18 is 6 percent of
X 18 is 6 percent of X so you normally
wouldn't even have to solve for it you
all you know is by looking at this
statement you couldn't solve for X and
if you can solve for X then you can just
multiply that times 0.15 and you'll have
the answer to the original statement so
you immediately know that statement 1 is
if you don't believe me you can just
write this out of this equation 18 is
equal to 6% of X and then you just solve
for X so 18 divided by 0.06 and then
multiply it times 0.15 and you get your
answer problem number two our statement
number two 2/3 of X is 200 2/3 of X is
equal to 200 once again all you you look
at this you say this is a simple
equation I can solve for X here if I
solve for X here then I just substitute
it back here and I will know what 15% of
X is and I would be done so each of
these statements individually are
sufficient to answer our question what
is 15% of X 35 now if I have to go
through the exercise of actually solving
for that because I think you understand
what I'm talking about 35 oh I like
these so they say 30 3.2 rectangle
rectangle triangle or Delta 6 and they
say if rectangle and Delta or triangle
each represent single digits in the
decimal above okay so this is a decimal
I thought that it might be operation so
this is a decimal so it's four digits
behind the decimal spot what does
rectangle represent so we want to know
what does this decimal what what's the
digit right here so the statements
statement number one tells us when the
decimal is rounded to the nearest tenth
3.2 is the result the nearest tenth so
when you round what you do is you look
at if we're rounding to the nearest
tenth we look at this number right we
look at the rectangle and if the
rectangle is 5 or greater we would round
up so we would get to three point three
if the rectangle is less than five is
then we would round down to two so we
know this statement number one tells us
that rectangle is less than five and we
know it's it's greater than or equal to
zero because it's a digit so it's zero
one two three or four right so because
it's zero
two three or four that's rectangle but
that by itself does not allow us to
figure out what rectangle is now
statement number two statement number
two tells us when the decimal is rounded
to the nearest hundredths to the nearest
hundredth three point two four is the
result three point two four is the
result when you round to the nearest
hundredth okay so this is this is
interesting now okay so this number here
is either going to be so when you're
rounding to something it's either going
to be either rounding down or rounding
up so this tells us so this number right
here can either be three so we already
know it can be zero one two or three or
four but which of these numbers when you
round them could be rounded up or down
to four well if if we have if the
triangle you know this could be two
three five right one let me give you one
scenario we could have two three point
let me three point two three five six
right where this is the rectangle and
this is triangle so this would round to
three point two four you could also have
three point two four one six where this
is the rectangle and this is the
triangle and either of these would round
to three point two four so this tells us
essentially that the rectangle has to be
either three or four has to be three or
four but and and this tells us that it's
either 0 1 2 3 or 4 but even when you
use them individually they don't tell
you exactly what the rectangle is and we
use them together you can just narrow
down to three or four which just
statement two alone tells you so this
actually turns out that when you use
both statements together you still can't
get the answer you'd either need a third
term there or we would have to have a
little bit more information about what
the triangle is if they told us that the
triangle is
it is you know rounds upward you know is
greater than five or less than five or
something like that then we could figure
out what the rectangle is so the answer
here is e if I haven't missed something
that they're together both statements
are not sufficient to answer the
question thirty-six the profit from the
sale of a certain appliance increases
though not proportionally with the
number of units sold the profit it
increases but not proportionally with
the number so it's not you know the
profits do not equal just some constant
times units it equals you know maybe
some constant times units squared or
something like that
did the profit exceed four million on
sales of 380,000 units so is profit
greater than four million this one's
interesting when units when units is
equal to 380
okay let's see if we can figure this out
so they say that the profit exceeds two
million on sales of two hundred thousand
so statement one says profit is greater
than two million when units is equal to
two hundred okay now if if they told us
that the profit was proportional to
units then we could say oh well if if we
increase units from two hundred to 380
then we're not doubling the units so
then we can't be well it still would be
ambiguous because not saying it profit
equals two they're saying that profit is
greater than two so this actually still
doesn't give me a lot of information
statement number two I'm doing a
different color statement number two
says the profit exceeds five million on
sales of so this isn't profit exceeds
five million on sales of 350,000 units
or 350,000 units okay so this is
interesting so this tells us that when
units are 350 up
profit has already in there greater than
five million so they're definitely
greater than four million and noticed
that that they told us that the profit
from the sale of certain appliance
increases though not proportionally with
the number of units sold so if when we
if we made more than five million
dollars when there's 350 thousand units
we know that when you go from 350
thousand to three hundred eighty
thousand we know from the statement of
the problem that the profit has to
increase we don't know by how much but
it's going to increase so the profit was
already greater than five million it's
going to increase above five million so
statement two tells us that the profit
is definitely gonna be above five
million so it's definitely gonna be
above four million so statement two
alone is enough and statement one is
actually tells us very little
information because we don't know you
know how there's a profit change as you
incremental II add units maybe every
every other you maybe every unit above
two hundred thousand that you add you
get like you know a millionth of a penny
and then it you know it doesn't tell you
anything or maybe you get a million
pennies so it's very hard to tell
problem number thirty actually let me
see I'm already at ten minutes let me do
that in the next video see you soon